all right so uh we have a 2020 Nissan
Rogue customer lost the only key
so uh we'll have to create it from
scratch the car is locked so we'll have
to pick the lock open and for this one
we're going to use the leashing let's
start
all right we need to open a Nissan Rogue
2020 we're gonna use a lychee
Anderson 14.
and uh
we're gonna pick the lock open
[Applause]
so on this lichi we have 10
numbers from 1 to 10.
but in the door there is only from 3 to
10.
so first I'm going to slide it in
make sure that everything
is springy
that's a tight lock very tight lock
but
all right now I'm going to put a little
bit of pressure
and every every wafer that's binding I'm
gonna pick
[Music]
and this is how it's picked
so now the door is open
all right after we open the door
we can start working on the ignition to
make a key
so the ignition is a pushed to start and
uh
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a universal
remote for this vehicle
I'm going to use otel km100
in order to generate it all right
so I'm using a
Hotel Universal Remote
[Music]
so I'm using a universal remote I need
to put a battery inside there is a
battery
so now first I need to because it's a
universal it can fit many models and
years
first we want to make sure that we write
it to this specific group of vehicles
and then we can program it to the car so
I'm going to go to Universal key
I'm gonna go to
Nissan
I'm gonna go to Rogue
I can look up here
and we have 19 to 2022 but she had five
buttons this is the one with the five
buttons
so we're gonna go this one
19 to 22 433 megahertz
and it has the five buttons I'm gonna do
generate Universal key
now that's going to take
about three minutes to write it down and
then we can go and program it to the
vehicle foreign
[Music]
the universally transform it to a Nissan
Rogue FCC like the same serial number
if I want another key I can put another
one and hit continue but since I'm only
doing one key I'm gonna hit completed
now what I like to do before
I go to the vehicle I would like to test
that there is a good battery in the
remote and also I can see the frequency
that it transmits now it says that it
should be 433 so that means the 434
should turn on
so the yellow light turns on that means
it registered to the right frequency so
now I'm gonna go ahead and program it to
the vehicle
so I'm gonna connect
the uh connector the dongle
to the OBD which is right underneath
here
and I'm gonna have a seat
first of all
I'm going to connect
connected to the dongle
there you go
all right so now we are still here so
instead of going back to the main menu
and coming and going again in the menu
to find the uh the the immobilizer you
have the button here immobilizer so it's
gonna already choose the year make and
model
all right turn on the Azure lights
turn on the ignition if the ignition
cannot be turned on press ok to continue
of course we don't have a key so it
cannot turn on
just gonna check to make sure that the
key is not here it says key ID incorrect
they do not have a key pair
[Music]
all right now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna go to heart function
smart key learning
it's gonna ask for the pin it's going to
read it by itself execution for this
function will erase all learn keys of
the vehicle prepare all keys in the
vehicle at most Four Keys can be learned
you want to continue yes
turn on turn off the ignition turn on
the other lights open and closed the
driver door
[Music]
okay
all right the BCM code is
for twenty
[Music]
okay so there is a risk between 2014 and
17 but we are 20 20 so there is no
problem
all right
place the original smart key against the
ignition so I'm gonna put it right here
next to the start button without pushing
it
and hit OK
I'm gonna hear two beeps
there you go
[Music]
okay so now we need to to push the
ignition on
very short push and we're gonna see the
red security light blink five times but
I'm gonna push it with
with the start key so and I leave it
next to it
there you go one two three four five so
that's already registered
I'm gonna do okay on the thing on the
machine and it's going to tell me turn
off the ignition
I'm gonna press again to turn it off and
hit OK program success continue to
program the next one no
all right so it says press and hold
press the start button and attach the
first learning smart key
within five seconds to the instrument
automatically will light up so I'm gonna
press it
very good and hit okay
please turn the ignition and wait three
seconds and it says steering lock
registration complete
hit okay
and success so that means we can turn
off the hazard lights
we can test
that works I'm going to press on the
break
and
voila very easy
[Music]
so in case you're in a Cape Coral Fort
Myers a sterile Lee Collier in Charlotte
County and you need any extra key or all
keys lost you can always give us a call
and we'll be more than happy to help you
make sure to like the video and
subscribe and if you have any questions
write it down in the comments I would
love to answer thank you for watching